I was thinking today yesterday as we've
been talking extensively about Donald
Trump's tax plan the abortive and
disastrous tax plan that he's proposed
that the Syrian bombing has really been
forgotten by so many in the United
States already I'm guessing you remember
that sort of pointless and fruitless
bombing of Syria by airstrike that
Donald Trump ordered a couple of weeks
ago 59 I believe was the number Tomahawk
missiles it was a strike that was likely
illegal under both US and international
law it accomplished nothing the next day
the runway the airport area that was the
target of the strike was up and running
planes were flying in and out of there
Donald Trump saw kids being gassed on
television by the Assad regime and
decided to send some missiles but
nothing changed and now we're on to tax
plans
we haven't heard whether that strike was
part of some broader strategy of Donald
Trump's very very doubtful guy barely
even understands what's going on there
how could it possibly be part of a
larger strategy
no one has forced Trump's hand to get
him to actually present what the point
of that strike was and what the broader
plan is if there even is one and Donald
Trump has not had to explain the legal
rationale after he very publicly said
under President Obama that if Obama went
into Syria he would need congressional
approval and by the way that it didn't
make sense to go into Syria that would
just cause problems Donald Trump
choosing to do airstrikes in Syria
forgetting or choosing to ignore the
correct statement he made that President
Obama would have needed congressional
approval didn't seek congressional
approval and has offered no explanation
whatsoever for why he did not do that
it's also kind of hard to even call it
an attack when Trump phoned ahead to let
Russia know that it was coming and then
again the airfield that was hit somehow
managed to still be operational and was
used to launch planes later a
by some accounts the same day or
certainly the next day so my broader
thought on this is this is part of the
sort of wall of chaos and BS strategy
and this plays into Steve bannon's ideas
I remember that a couple of weeks ago I
pointed out that Steve Bannon was
removed from the principles of the
National Security Council I agreed with
it he never should have been on the
National Security Council to begin with
but after all nothing much changed
number one
Steven Bannon was still in the moral
hago Situation Room
along with Jared Kushner and Trump and
military officials during the strikes of
Syria of the Syrian airstrikes that
we've been talking about so he's clearly
still very very involved and the wall of
BS idea where it's a crazy tax plan
there's a bogus replacement to the first
Obamacare replacement attempt multiple
failed immigration bands and Ivanka's at
the White House it is a wall of BS and
it plays into bannon's ideas of
deconstructing the administrative state
and that's something that he's talked
about wanting to do and if you are
constantly creating chaos and constantly
creating scandal upon scandal and
confusing and and shifting narratives
and sending your entire team out there
basically to just lie unabashedly that
goes towards this broader idea of
deconstructing the administrative state
there's too much to keep up with we
don't know what Trump is doing we don't
know what Trump is thinking we can't
keep track of how many cronies are
benefiting from what Donald Trump is
doing including Trump and his family
himself and it is all playing really
really well into what we know or Steve
bannon's goals priorities and ideas and
talking to people here at the conference
in Las Vegas I don't want to call it a
unanimous consensus but when when I talk
to all sorts of different media hosts
about who do we think is really running
the show the the general consensus is
that it's Steve Bannon and the level to
which that is horrifying is you know
almost beyond words I'm having trouble
finding the words later on today's
program
we'll be revisiting my classic interview
with Pastor James David Manning this is
the guy who thought that Starbucks was
using the DNA of gay men to make their
lattes taste better how he knew that it
would make them taste better
I don't know but I did ask him that
during our interview so we're going to
be getting to that a little bit later
also we will be dealing with audience
questions a little bit later today so
thanks to everybody who's joining us
back after this I'm really glad to tell
you about this new sponsor of the show
that has launched with us this week
Hagia dab the hosting specialist they
offer a range of hosting options that is
both affordable and flexible this
includes dedicated hosting virtual
private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions as well as
colocation services tailored to your
business and to your project taga dab is
really proud of their expert hosting
specialists with many companies it's
hard to really get the experts on the
phone who can actually help you with
what you're doing with your project with
your business and with taga dev you can
do exactly that they currently have a
nine point seven out of ten trust pilot
review rating that is excellent under
the trust pilot rating algorithm with a
growing number of people interested in
moving their businesses and projects to
the cloud you can get a ten-pound credit
that's ten British pounds to all new
customers signing up gives you an
opportunity to try the service even
though taga dab is in the UK you can be
anywhere you want and to take advantage
of that sign up credit of 10 pounds go
to sign up CAG adapt comm slash TDPS
that is sign up dot ta ga da b.com /t
dps